up next the new book the blue death
public health researcher Robert Morris
analyzes the connection between water
quality and disease he warns of the
dangers of drinking polluted water which
he says is a serious problem in America
and around the world this is just under
an hour it's a real pleasure to be here
boy it it took me a long time to get
here tonight I I guess you could say it
took me about five years when I started
writing this book five years ago I
thought it was not because I thought
that a book on dirty water and diarrhea
would make a summer blockbuster actually
I wrote the book because I felt I had no
choice but to make the story of dirty
water and diarrhea into a summer
blockbuster in 20 years as a physician
and scientist doing research on drinking
water and health I had seen study after
study showing that we had real problems
with our water supply but that
conversation never seemed to get beyond
the small circle of scientists
bureaucrats politicians and I had to
expand the circle I had to get the
information about our water out to the
people who needed it which i believe is
everyone who drinks water and to do that
I knew I had to take this critical
information and weave it into a
compelling and readable story
fortunately for me the history of
drinking water is packed with tales of
genius political intrigue and tragedy
you could say that story begins in 1848
when a young british physician by the
name of John snowed dug into his savings
to publish a report that should have
changed the world England was in the
grip of a horrifying cholera epidemic
people were dying right and left and
snow simply argued that drinking water
was spreading the disease nobody
believed in no one could imagine that
something invisible odorless and without
taste something that could hide in the
transparency of a glass of water
could kill actually spend about a third
of the book with snow because his is a
remarkable story of an inconvenient
truth at odds with money and old ways of
thinking sounds familiar doesn't it this
first excerpt takes place at a time when
snow was working on a critical study of
the water supply to strengthen his
arguments about the dangers of
contaminated water on the morning of
friday September first 1855 as the
people of Soho stepped outside they
found that a cooling breeze had arrived
from the Northeast the heat wave had
faded but something far worse had
arrived in the dark of night word of the
horror buzz through the neighborhood
almost everyone it seems knew someone
who was dying no one understood the
scope of this disaster better than
Reverend Henry whitehead the priest of
st. Luke's Church which stood just one
block from Broad Street throughout the
previous evening and into the night he
had walked the streets of his parish in
long flowing robes ministering to the
afflicted and their families for many
the appearance of his broad friendly
face gave them a moment of reassurance
in an otherwise desperate night when he
finally made his way home through the
dense mix of mist and cold cold smoke to
the small apartment he shared with his
brother he sensed he was facing a devil
unlike any he had encountered in his 29
years he would spend much of the next
day delivering last rites to the dying
word of the emerging tragedy had yet to
reach the affluent district just across
Regent Street where Jon Snow was
immersed in a study of the London water
supply his office was filled with maps
death records and the data he had
assembled over the preceding year after
six years of struggling to convince the
medical establishment that drinking
water could spread cholera jon snow felt
he was finally closing in
on the proof that might muffle his
critics the ground itself would need to
shake to divert his attention from the
task at hand as the Sun rose on that
Friday morning Jon Snow had no notion of
the horrifying turn of events so close
to the desk where he SAT piecing
together the story of the London water
supply he could not see the first black
windowless carriage as it appeared from
behind the curtain of fog that the cold
air had draped across broad street he
could not hear the horses protest as
their driver also dressed in black
pulled at their reins bringing their
carriage to a stop in front of a
four-story building two men climbed down
and entered the French door with a
stretcher they climbed to an apartment
marked by a row of shuttered windows
minutes later they emerged carrying a
draped lifeless figure before they had
finished loading the corpse into the
back of their carriage the sound of
hoofbeats and steel-rimmed wheels
signaled the arrival of another crew
with the same grim mission over the
course of that day a fleet of hearses
rolled steadily through the district
again and again these faceless wagons
came to collect their tragic cargo more
than 60 people living the area around
Broad Street died on that Friday as each
hearse arrived neighbors watched quietly
registering the address of the deceased
and wondering where the next would spot
well snow eventually convinces many of
the physicians and scientists in England
that he's right but policymakers fail to
fully grasp the importance of his ideas
until Louis Pasteur and Robert cook
invent the science of microbiology and
tracked down the agent responsible for
cholera but the debate continued in 1893
40 years after snow some of the most
senior figures in public health still
refused to believe that waterborne
pathogens were causing cholera
so this second excerpt takes place in
Germany at that time in 1893 Robert
cooks laboratory in Berlin received a
strange request professor max from
pettenkofer director of the Institute of
Hygiene and Munich wanted some cholera
the fact that he wanted collar was not
remarkable cokes lab had maintained a
culture of Vibrio cholera since the
outbreak in Hamburg and may have been
the only source of the bacteria in
Germany anyone wanting to study color
would need a sample the thing that made
this request stand out was that
pettenkofer had no plans to study the
microbe in his own laboratory he was
convinced that the bacteria growing
[ __ ] culture media did not cause
cholera and saw no need to study it
further he did however have an
experiment in line despite the fact that
pettenkofer was a leading critic of [ __ ]
George Gaffney one of [ __ ] colleagues
prepared a sample to send pettenkofer
after all was the elder statesman of
Public Health in Germany Gaffney
packaged the sample with exceptional
care and sent it to Munich the sealed
vial within contained enough Vibrio
cholera to kill hundreds of people at 74
pettenkofer was one of Germany's most
senior scientists is with former
students in key positions throughout the
country pettenkofer was convinced that
cholera and drinking water could not by
itself cause the disease soon after
receiving the sample pettenkofer stood
before a small audience in a lecture
hall at his Institute he explained to
them his long-held belief that agents
released from damp soils were the real
cause of cholera [ __ ] comma shaped
bacteria might predispose one to the
disease he told them but in the absence
of appropriate atmospheric and hygienic
conditions it was harmless then he held
up the vial containing billions of
bacteria and told the audience that he
was now prepared to offer definitive
proof of his theory he then put the flow
ask to his lips tilted his head back and
consumed its contents I won't spoil the
book by telling you well but I'm not
exactly revealing the fate of Harry
Potter to tell you that the wisdom of
snow and [ __ ] eventually does prevail
soon cities around the world are
scrambling to find pure water supplies
or build plants to filter their water
these efforts together with the
introduction of chlorine helped
eliminate cholera typhoid and dysentery
as major causes of death in the
developed world and really made the
modern industrial city possible in the
second half of the 20th century two
things happened first we realized that
chemical contaminants could be a major
cause of illness and that even the
chlorine we were adding to make our
water safe was producing highly toxic
compounds second new microbes began to
emerge as causes of human disease with
this third excerpt where we are in
Milwaukee in 1993 and a mysterious
outbreak is overwhelming hospitals
around the city
if the battle against this outbreak had
become a war doctor calf to become one
of the commanders in the ground campaign
he had been called to see more and more
patients who were suffering from the
mysterious infection taps had enough
experience that he could often
identified by an organism just by the
pattern of signs and symptoms in his
patients but so far the pathogen had not
shown its hand then as he stood waiting
for an elevator another physician pulled
him aside task colleague was caring for
a woman with severe diarrhea hospital's
intensive care unit a tissue sample from
the lining of her small intestine had
shown something that looked like
Cryptosporidium a finding of
Cryptosporidium by itself would not have
been unusual it often appeared as a
cause of severe diarrhea in people with
AIDS even the fact that it put this
woman in the ICU was not extraordinary
except for one thing sheep not have AIDS
as soon as he could calf made his way to
the ICU to see the woman himself in any
Hospital the intensive care unit defines
a special territory where death holds
watch as modern medicine wheels all of
its technical muscle and defiance like
all physicians he had learned to
approach the ICU with a calm remove that
allowed him to focus on the intellectual
challenge of saving lives as he entered
the woman's room a pale yellow line
traced the echo of her rapid heartbeat
on the monitor above her bed he gazed
down at her frail body and examined her
sunken features a pump drone in the
background as it steadily pushed saline
through a catheter into the veins of her
withered arm that pump was keeping her
alive he lifted her hand and took her
twisted fingers in his own years of the
slow and ultimately losing struggle
against rheumatoid arthritis had
contorted them at a tortured angle her
skin had turned sin and paper like from
the side effects of the drugs used to
treat her arthritis drugs did also
suppress her immune system
fact that this woman was overrun with
Cryptosporidium seemed unusual the drug
she was taking for arthritis had
weakened your immune system but not to
the extent that aids was nonetheless
kaif knew that strange things happened
to medicine he was considering the
possibility that this was nothing more
than an interesting case when his pager
went off he recognized the number as the
microbiology laboratory in the end that
outbreak sickened 400,000 people put
4,000 in the hospital and killed more
than 100 but the truly staggering thing
to me is not those numbers but the fact
the water during that outbreak met all
federal standards for drinking water in
this next excerpt I want to describe
well I'm going to read the introduction
to the chapter that talks about the
government response both to that
outbreak and to increasing information
that the byproducts of chlorinating our
drinking water we're creating serious
toxic chemicals with possibly they were
possibly causing cancer and even still
birth and birth defects barely
Washington rushes to correct
environmental problems with all the
speed and agility of a glacier on
sedatives during the 1980s the
legislative glacier ground to a halt as
the Reagan administration systematically
eliminated funding for drinking water
research in the EPA refused to issue new
regulations in 1986 Congress ordered the
EPA to issue an array of new tap water
regulations but the EPA simply did
nothing until an alliance of citizens
groups took them to court the agency
finally buckled under a court order and
issued new rules in the early 90s in
1992 they wrought the arrival of a new
administration brought hope that the
process would again move forward but
treatment plants are expensive and the
drinking water industry resisted then
came Milwaukee in many ways the
evisceration of the EPA budget for
drinking water research and the
subsequent failure to correct that
imbalance made the disaster in Milwaukee
possible even inevitable that outbreak
could have been predicted and should
have been prevented several studies not
only from academic researchers but from
the industry's own experts had shown the
Cryptosporidium assists routinely
surfaced routinely occurred in surface
water throughout the United States and
were frequently present in treated
drinking water the outbreak in a Georgia
City serve notice that a massive
outbreak in a treated water supply was
far more than a theoretical possibility
despite all those warnings neither the
EPA nor the industry sound of the alarm
that silence made it possible for the
water supply of a major city to operate
a descriptive beryllium did not exist
after Milwaukee the drinking water
industry could no longer ignore the
threat or so it seemed
that process flogged on for about 13
years drinking water just doesn't seem
to light many political fires I don't
think anyone has ever been elected on a
platform of digging up streets repairing
leaking pipes or upgrading water
treatment plants but there are real
problems with our water supply in 2005
the American Society of Civil Engineers
gave a letter grade to every area of
infrastructure in the United States
drinking water and wastewater
infrastructure across the country
received a grade of D minus and if we
don't act that will become a failing
grade but for all the magnitude of the
crisis of water in this country the most
horrifying crisis of all involves water
in the developing world today we can
expect 6,000 people to die from lack of
clean water most of them will be
children this is a humanitarian crisis
of epic proportions and if we ignore it
that disaster will find its way back to
us this last excerpt I want to read
takes us to Africa in 1994 when Rwandan
refugees were screaming across the
border with a year
as the Sun rose over zai year alone
cargo helicopter lumbered through the
shadows of the virunga mountains ahead
past the steaming summit of the neuron
gongo volcano was Lake Teague the
highest lake in Africa in the 19th
century vacationing colonists had
flocked to the shores of this beautiful
mountain lake for a respite from the
busy work of exploiting the region's
natural wealth in the summer of nineteen
ninety-four it's deep blue waters gave
rise to the worst outbreak of waterborne
disease in human history an
epidemiological perfect storm inside the
helicopter less Roberts and
epidemiologists for the World Health
Organization peered out at the lush
jungle that clung to the mountainside
beyond the mountains Rwanda stretched
out toward the sunrise ahead on the
ancient lava flow that separated the
mountains from the lake the city of Goma
seemed to be under siege it's surrounded
by the makeshift shelters of hundreds of
thousands of refugees just two months
earlier dr. Roberts had been in Atlanta
completing his training as an
epidemiologist with the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention now he
was flying to the heart of a surreal
world ruled by death and disease he had
been working with the wh 0 to monitor
the epidemic and knew the statistics as
well as anyone but they could only hint
at the reality on the ground the scale
of the epidemic in Goma and the speed
with which it was unfolding stunned even
the most seasoned veterans with
experience and refugee camps throughout
the world when the helicopter landed dr.
Roberts slipped through the cargo area
of the airport and in a few moments
disappeared into the confusion that was
gonna a red-haired cork bobbing on a
dark-skinned African ocean dr. Roberts
made his way from the airport to the
command and control center of the United
Nations High Commission on refugees
officials they are directed him to the
medical facilities of medicine du monde
in the Muslim
inga camp one of the three camps around
Goma as his motorcycle taxi entered the
camp and rattled slowly across the sea
of human misery les Roberts began to
grasp the unique horror of Goma along
the two mile roads in the airport
hundreds of corpses sometimes stacked
two or three high awaited pick up by
workers in the camp the dead were not
the victims of tootsie soldiers a far
more ruthless predator had been waiting
for the Hutus as they arrived in Goma
long before the coming of the rwandan a
microscopic killer had found its own
refuge amid the poverty of the year for
years it had moved slowly from once a
year into the next leaving a trail of
disease behind the sudden appearance of
the refugees exhausted malnourished and
thirsty from their flights presented
this killer with a rare opportunity
within days of their arrival an
explosion of cholera had begun to
consume the refugees on reaching wodonga
dr. Roberts went directly to the
medicine du monde cholera treatment
center after two months of compiling
death tolls and the unfolding disaster
in Rwanda would finally have a chance to
intervened the faceless numbers had not
prepared him for what he found more than
a thousand cholera victims were crammed
into an open area the size of a baseball
diamond every five minutes one of them
would die desperate aid workers moved
among the diseased trying to help those
that could be saved with the meagre and
entirely inadequate resources at hand
we can't wait for bridges to collapse
and levies to fail before we do
something about our infrastructure we
cannot wait for the next waterborne
disaster before we decide that what safe
water is important we cannot experiment
on ourselves and our children by
accepting the presence of toxic
chemicals in our water supply and we
cannot allow dirty water to take a life
every 14 seconds in the developing world
because our attention is elsewhere there
is not just one inconvenient truth about
what we are doing to our environment
there are many the story of drinking
water is one of them so on that note
thank you for your time and I would be
happy to answer any questions and I've
been told to make sure that you make
sure you wait for the man in the blue
shirt before you say anything so when we
start laying back there yes I wondered
if you would comment coming from Seattle
I'm sure you know a Bert schnucks who's
been to a rock nine time and what
happened in 1991 I just read it for the
record of municipal court so I'd like to
repeat it briefly in january nineteen
ninety-one our six-week air war on iraq
began over 120,000 allied sorties were
carried out on the second day all
electrical generating sites with
exception of two on borders were bond
not only ending electricity but water
purification and distribution and sewage
treatment since these plants were
dependent on electricity on the second
day of the war CENTCOM received a USB I
a message predicting epidemics of
cholera hepatitis and
typhoid we are indebted to professor of
Public Health Thomas Maggie for
discovering this memo I wanted to
mention the episode on 60 minutes for
the Secretary of State said yes it was
worth it that five hundred thousand
Iraqi children had died that was
basically from what what had happened
here that the drinking water supply was
completely destroyed vert shock says
there is no safe drinking water in Iraq
now I I mean I I'm not intimately
familiar with with the situation in Iraq
but from what I've heard it's really
it's pretty horrific in terms of the
inadequacy of the water supply it's only
on for a short period during the day I
can tell you I wouldn't drink it yeah
wait a second I forgot to tell you
something in 1990 Saddam Hussein had
improved safe drinking water to
eighty-seven percent of his population
all the urban population had safe
drinking water we completely destroyed
that setup well I think warfare natural
disasters take a tremendous toll on the
things that support us all those things
that we take for granted become either
unavailable or damaged in ways that that
really make the viability of the city
they call that into question and to
bring that story back home because I
think your point about Iraq is a very
good one there was recent news out of
New Orleans where the water supply they
air is leaking 50 million gallons a day
into the ground and the viability of
that city is in question for nothing
more than the inadequacy of the water
supply and what it's going to take to
repair it 50,000 leaks from that water
system see one week to the one in blue
here first you're on I noticed that you
are not drinking a vial of cholera but
you are drinking a bottle of glass of
water is it bottled water filtered water
or from our own lake whatcom that's a
loaded question I brought my own it's
filtered water from Seattle yeah that's
true I should give you credit for the
glass your glass my water go ahead you
know being from the West where water
rights are so important to us all and
you know are such a hot topic now then
this move toward privatization of
aquifers and water supply do you have an
opinion whether control of water quality
should stay within the public sector or
what the impact of private privatization
of water supplies my me if the public
sector isn't doing a great job now will
that improve or waiting well you know
it's it's hard to answer questions about
water in general because it does tend to
be a very local issue you may have
situations where small communities
simply don't have the resource the
microbiology laboratories the kind of
resources that you might need I know
there's some very good people in
of these businesses that are involved in
buying water supplies but my gut
response is that we should be really
very careful with this legacy of our
water supplies you know there is nothing
more precious and I find it a little
scary to see it on the market to see our
water supplies on the market I mean you
have companies this is a huge global
industry now where large corporations
are coming in and buying a flutter
supplies yeah well as well as my
question and what I agree with but you
just said it can't imagine turning your
water supply over somebody is profit
driven in terms of the effect on the
rest of us but the question ahead why is
it so much disparity between the
protection of the watersheds of in our
water source we've got the jet skis and
powerful and septic systems all around
the lake and their other cities where
they are barbed wire and you're not
allowed to even walk on the property on
the slopes leading into the water supply
could we have some I know this political
I suppose why don't we have a uniform
standard at least some protection for
the water ship this is a this is a
terrific question and it I try to
emphasize in the book that it is
absolutely critical that you begin with
the water supply if you don't if you
compromise the water supply the rest of
the game is ketchup you know you're
you're just trying to see if you can
filter out the gunk that you put in
there and so I I think you have to have
the maximum protection of the watershed
possible now you know realistically if
somebody is drinking out of the
Mississippi River that's pretty tricky
watershed to protect but I think we
should really push watershed protection
to the maximum and I think filtration
plants belong in there as part of the
mix I think you need multiple barriers
to protect public health
congratulating me for writing such a
thrilling look I i would have injuries
onra you know environmental thrillers
coming up here but I hope yeah I don't
know one I had a good question and one
of them is where D what I only got to
read nine through twelve chapters but um
what is your as an epidemiologist how do
you look at the chlorinated byproducts
the estrogen mimicking estrogen I
endocrine disrupting chemicals to those
are two question that's one question I
have my illness maybe because the
chlorine is coming from something we add
to protect public health so it's a
trickier question in some ways because
should it be in the water should
chlorination byproducts be in the water
I mean if these were food additives we
wouldn't allow them ok so it's they
don't ideally you don't want them in the
water on the other hand without that
disinfectant you run a serious risk of
water-borne diseases so you have to
balance risks estrogen mimicking
compounds there is evidence now that in
fact the EPA did a study that eighty
percent of the streams they looked at
had residues from pharmaceutical
medicate from pharmaceuticals
medications there are a broad array of
compounds of mimic estrogen to the
extent where treated sewage of fish
swimming near treated sewage male fish
get turned into female fish so this is
this is a serious business and it needs
to be much more aggressively regulated
yeah so those so would you say those
those types of chemicals should also be
filtered from our
watch the play I mean well it's not safe
to have those in our water fight and the
fact is most water treatment plants were
not originally designed to take
chemicals out of the water they were
designed to filter out pathogens and so
chemicals have much easier time getting
through you mentioned that company in
Arizona is is scheduled to go online
with a water treatment plant that
actually treats the sewage to the to a
point that it I was like that is there
you know that they figure at some point
I believe it was Tucson but I think most
of the Southwest is looking at this
there was an amazing study that just
came out in Australia where the
Australian waterworks concluded that
almost every major city in australia was
going to have to find a new source of
drinking water within the decade now a
new source of drinking water where is
that coming from well what that means is
d salinization recycling waste water I
mean that's a that's a grim scenario but
it's one that we all have to think about
as populations grow and water supplies
become tighter technology exists or it's
just being developed it exists but why
that's an old unsettling alternative I
would I would look some other in some
other directions before I started doing
that what do you do when the treatment
plant fails
he went back to you i was born in the
mississippi river by the way back to
your your glass of water you're drinking
i'm assuming that your that your little
carafe there is a glass lined and not
with PVC plastic I've been hearing
recently that the plastic that was that
our so expensive water comes in that we
buy is causing us a lot of problems as
well with these as these hormone issues
and did you write about that in your
book at all yeah I I talk about bottled
water tonight and all the packaging as
well or you know there's only so many
ways you can condemn bottle water before
you but but I think nope but you know
people but the fact is people buy it for
a reason they're spending 15 billion
dollars on bottled water because they
think there's something wrong with
what's coming out of the tap and they're
right so I don't think people should be
I don't think people should be using
bottled water as their major source of
drinking water but it should give us
pause to think about our water supply do
you also in your book recommend they
home any kind of fun remedies for water
source water I really my concern about
that is what happened in fact we already
have this where you have a two-tiered
water supply I read recently that
somewhere on the order of twenty percent
of people have home filters on their tab
okay well then what about the other
eighty percent what about people who
can't afford a home filter it just to me
I few clean waters as a right
fundamentally and I think that people
that if we're going to do water filters
home water filters which I think are
under underutilized actually I mean I
think home water filters that utilities
should make that part of their whole
treatment plan because what's between
the water treatment plant
and your tab is pipes that are rotting
okay I mean literally falling apart so
you know you the EPA tends to regulate
what comes out of the treatment plant
but I'm a little more concerned about
what happens on the way to your tab
let's see it's going to be I think you
were next and then I'll send them back
your way how do you feel about the use
of ozone to purify water and the
fluoride issue all right let's see I
didn't write that book the fluoride book
but okay ozone ozone is a very
interesting alternative to chlorine it
does not produce a lot that the
chlorinated compounds there are some
concerns about some of the chemicals
that do form i mean the tricky thing is
here you want to add something to the
water that's going to kill everything in
it only it can't do any harm to us so
it's a fine balance but I think ozone is
very promising it's widely used in
Europe and I I think it has a lot of
promise as an alternative depending on
the community as far as fluoride you
know the National Academy of Sciences
handle concluded that the amount of full
of the fluoride in water that's added to
drinking water to increase the fluoride
was not did not pose a significant risk
but that they should lower the amount
that's allowed in water so communities
worth naturally occurring at high levels
should be removing more of it I think
the question there's some question and I
am about the utility of fluoride in
terms of protecting teeth and that's an
argument that I haven't delved into but
as far as the risk I haven't seen a lot
of strong evidence
that the amount that's added just to
fluoridate water for drinking is or for
dental hygiene is harmful you can get me
on that one later in the back here in
Bellingham our water source is late
welcome and we have allowed around the
lake residential development and we
allow motor boats on the lake what do
you think of those two as a threat of
shoe we disallowing those and what
should a small town like ours be most
concerned about in a water source like
with late welcome I you know I know sort
of generically about lake whatcom and
the issues with algal blooms and the
fact that you have tremendous amount of
development around the edges of the lake
I think I think anything that can be
done to protect the watershed should be
done i think you know jet skis motor
boats I don't why do we why is that
necessary you know you really have to
ask flip the question around and say if
we're going to put at that water supply
at risk in any way is it essential and
that's a question that the community has
to ask itself but it's not a road I
would go down lightly in terms of
developing developing around a water
supply I think anything you can do to
protect the water supply should be done
yes
you're next oh you have to wait it oh oh
this one back I noticed as you mentioned
water supply bridges and there was
another Larry Levy's I think what you're
saying is we need to take more control
of our infrastructure or request or
demand that it be handled more
appropriately by the governing bodies
right do I understand you're correct i
think you've got it yeah I really now
infrastructure just ain't sexy and I
think it you know somehow it's got to be
a little sexier I mean we got to do
something about it or we're just going
to wait for the next bridge to collapse
we're just going to wait for the next
levy depend just like one addendum to
this and I've noticed it over the years
we are a very polite country we don't
we're almost like cheap we go along and
don't question is that part of the
problem with the water and the bridges
the twenty-five percent of our bridges
are hazardous what are we waiting for no
i don't know i think as a society in
many ways we are sleepwalking and we're
so diverted by everything of the popular
culture and everything else that it's
out there that we don't really we can't
keep our attention focused on some of
the things that truly matter thank you
make sure your next okay I wondered if
you had heard of a woman named Maude
Barlow who is of the Council of
Canadians who does a lot of water work
in canada and she had written a lot too
and she said that there have been
obviously oil would but she said that
the Wars of the future will be water or
had you ever heard that or well I think
there's no question I mean if there may
we may be seeing water wars already but
i would say within the decade we'll see
water wars i mean there was just it was
just in the news that settlers in israel
were taking the drinking cutting into
the drinking water supplies from the
palestinians and filling their swimming
pools I get pretty mad about that yeah
I come from Southern California and I
was a construction inspector at Hyperion
wastewater treatment plant and in the
late 90s I was involved in inspecting
close to a half a trillion dollars worth
of work and so if the one of the most
most prosperous countries in the world
is trying to scrape together enough
money to keep our infrastructure going
and keep clean water available to our
population what's the rest of the world
going to be doing how how do we help the
rest of the world that's a good question
you know I think that the situation in
the rest of the world is sufficiently
death dire that it takes less I mean the
return on investment is much greater
doing something in the developing world
and I also think that the developing
world is not using hundreds of gallons a
day per household to to function so they
need less water I mean we only drink
about less than 1% of the water that
comes into our house we do we actually
drink so you can do a lot with a little
when it comes to drinking water
especially in the developing world
can you give an example of a pure are
nearly pure water spots in a saltwater
cepot well there I can give examples of
water supplies that have very pure
source water Portland Seattle at least
one of the reservoirs in Seattle a car
essentially entirely protected
watersheds and have very good water now
I'm sure there are others particularly
on New York you know New York just there
was great fanfare because they just got
a waiver to go for another 10 years
without filtering their drinking water
which I find a little surprising since
the water supply for New York receives
treated sewage from 114 different
communities so I would filter it
thank you for coming today I've been
concerned about our lake whatcom water
supply for 10 or 12 years I operate a
website you're called lake whatcom org
which operates on the theme of we can't
afford to be wrong about our supply of
pure drinking water one of my missions
is citizen empowerment teaching telling
the people what the situation is and
what can be done so my questions to you
this evening are what should citizens
look for how should they be more
observant and more aware of the problems
potential are actual in their drinking
water supply and what in particular what
should they look at while watching the
water in the lake itself our water
source you mentioned the algae before
I'm aware of the concerns that the algae
blooms cause into the water system so
give us some clues to help these people
go out and be good stewards of the
watershed themselves give you two
answers one because there is most water
supplies have websites they have reports
that they publish and you can at least
learn from them what the water supply
comes from do they frequently violate
federal standards and do they what sort
of filtration do they have what kind of
treatment plants do they have but
there's a tremendous amount of
information that's not there and my
feeling is we need to make water
suppliers much more accountable and it's
interesting with in the 90s I advocated
that when they were changing the
drinking water treatment role as I said
you know these guys why don't we just
put a rule in saying they have to tell
us what's in the water this seems pretty
basic well I thought that was you know
it was obvious but I got actually got
vilified by in the press by some one
Republican senator for example who will
go unnamed for suggesting that although
that it was eventually passed and the
utilities turned it into something they
call the consumer confidence
pork and they issue it with a heavy dose
of spin and so I think that this is this
is just disingenuous this is our water
they should tell us what's in it it
should be like the labels on food and
stores it's just ridiculous that there
should be any reason to hide within our
water what the state of the pipes are
there should be a much more open
relationship between water suppliers and
the people who drink the water and the
lake how does that really well algae and
lake there's two reasons you might be
concerned about algin Utley at least 21
is when you have a lot of organic matter
in the lake and in water and you add
chlorine to it first of all you have to
add a lot more chlorine and you get much
higher levels of the chlorination
byproducts these chemicals that form
when chlorine combines with organic
matter in the water and so that's one
reason to be concerned there is also
reason to be concerned because some
algae actually produce toxins and I
don't know exactly what algae are in
lake whatcom but that's a that's a real
reason to be concerned about algae as
well plus the fact that the algae is
there means there's stuff coming in
there's nutrients coming into the lake
and you need to know what the source of
nutrients is any way in the back before
i moved to bellingham i lived in a
little town in british columbia called
Gibson's which was supposed to have the
purest water in the world came from an
aquifer so my question is how does the
water in the United States compared in
general with the water in Canada and
other Western nations people are bad for
water there are fewer people in Canada
there's fewer is less demand on the
water supplies so it's I would say in
general
the water in Canada is going to tend to
be cleaner just because there's there's
less pressure on it but beyond that very
general answer it's really it's hard to
answer your questions water is just a
such a site specific issue that it's
it's hard to give a broader answer to
that question yes private or community
water systems where the water is tested
everything the once a month which first
seems reassuring but then I think about
what about 29 days ago 30 days ago
everything was well yes so my question
is pretty personal then how frequently
should water be tested as an awful lot
on what kind of water you're talking
about if it now here if you're drawing
from ground water things are not going
to change very rapidly in a groundwater
supply so you know groundwater might not
need to be tested quite so often if
you're dealing with a surface water
supply a river that lots of people use
for lots of different things you need to
test it much more often and one of the
big challenges in regulating drinking
water is that you know the large cities
can test more often it costs money to
test and it's much tougher on smaller
communities to test the water and to
maintain that kind of vigilance that you
might want to have
one more hour the EPA standards even
adequate considering the levels the tiny
levels of hormone disruptor chemicals
chlorination byproducts that at our
cause problems with reproduction the EPA
tends to respond to an event by pushing
the standards incrementally forward
personally I would like to see much
tighter standards than currently exist
so in my mind I don't think they're
adequate but I'm also not paying the
bills so but having said that I do think
we can afford to spend a lot more on
drinking water than we do I don't know
many people who complain about their
drinking water bill busting their budget
the other question well thank you all
for coming I was a pleasure Robert
Morris is an environmental
epidemiologist for more on the blue
depth visit the publishers website at
HarperCollins com